desde georgia hasta maine a 19 estados
en la costa este de eeuu están bajo
alerta por una de las tormentas de nieve
más grandes que han afectado esta parte
del país en los últimos dos años
la tormenta que la semana pasada impactó
a california afectará a más de 100
millones de personas en esta parte del
país con hasta 45 centímetros de nieve y
durará hasta el miércoles por la mañana
algunos aeropuertos como el john
f.kennedy en la ciudad de nueva york han
cancelado ya el 75% de sus vuelos además
las terminales de buses y el servicio de
trenes en esta parte del país también
están en gran parte cerrados hasta el
martes en la tarde ciudades como
washington filadelfia boston baltimore y
estados como con eric roth
island están cerrando sus centros de
vacunación y pruebas para el cob y algo
que le preocupa a las autoridades
teniendo en cuenta que la distribución
de la vacuna ya ha sido lenta por su
parte los colegios también están
cerrados en las principales ciudades
de la costa este hasta el miércoles que
es cuando el clima mejorará en
washington hasta la votación en el
senado de alejandro mayorkas como un
nuevo secretario de seguridad nacional
tuvo que ser aplazada por los efectos de
la tormenta